han pasado seis años
seis años en los que se han adaptado a
la vida como una familia de tres Andrew
Amaury y su padre Bruno acuden a
regularmente al Memorial de Niza que
rinde homenaje a las víctimas del
atentado
está a la izquierda tenía el pelo rizado
y los ojos negros y marrones
[Música]
esperan que el juicio Arroyo luz sobre
cómo se desarrolló el atentado
como todo el mundo creemos que se sepa
la verdad
queremos que se conozcan la
responsabilidades de las personas
me gustaría saber porque lo hizo eso es
todo
14 de julio de 2016 día de la bastilla
la fiesta nacional francesa cuando el
espectáculo de fuegos artificiales llega
a su fin un hombre con un camión se
abalanza sobre la multitud
antes de que la policía lo mate a tiros
dos kilómetros de Carnicería 86 vidas
perdidas
incluyendo amino cuyo hijo menor sufrió
una herida en la pierna
nos encontramos por primera vez con
ellos unos meses después del ataque los
niños tenían solo 7 y 5 años en ese
momento mamá todavía me persigue un poco
una noche que cambió sus vidas para
siempre años después Todavía están sus
mentes
todo lo que puedo recordarles es que
estaba en un banco mi hermano estaba
cerca y va hacia mi madre
pero vi que el camión se acercaba Así
que lo agarré por la camiseta sin pensar
realmente en lo que estaba pasando
[Música]
pienso en ello muy a menudo y cuando lo
hago Estoy un poco triste
ahora Bruno debe criar solo a sus hijos
Se preocupaba mucho por ellos por su
futuro era una mujer maravillosa muy
trabajadora siempre les digo a Maury
Andrew que ella es su referente
los tres se siguen dando paseos por la
calle en la que se produjo el atentado
una forma de mantenerse fuertes y no
ceder al miedo
[Música]